[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans sa hotte qu'a dit
merci jimmy notre invité ce matin jean
benoît dinel bonjour bonjour et mes
voeux à tous les éditeurs parce qu'on
entre dans la période
on peut le faire jusqu'au 31 tout à fait
tout à fait mes meilleurs voeux à toutes
et à tous jean-benoît desnel vous êtes
éditeur co-organisateur de la nuit des
idées vous faites aussi un peu dans la
diplomatie culturelle on va dire ça
comme ça et vous êtes venu nous parler
d'un rendez vous jeudi soir prochain ce
jeudi 28 janvier qui va se tenir donc à
la villa chanteclerc à fort de france
alors la nuit des idées au delà de cette
de ce titre
concernant un concept alors c'est la
sixième édition de la nuit des idées
cette année au delà du titre attrayant
c'est vrai de cette manifestation de
cette forme peut-être d'happening comme
on dit représentations au sens
d'événements de performance situation
qui peut être considéré même comme une
expression artistique en tout cas
culturel qu'est ce que cette nuit des
idées c'est un moment d'être nocturne
donc pendant lequel des personnes vont
ben on parle idées vont penser vont
phosphorer du cerveau c'est un concept
qui a été mise en place par le ministère
des affaires étrangères dont
l'organisateur et tous et l'institut
français l'institut français ce sont des
entités qui sont placés dans le monde
présent avec latine présent dans la
caraïbe dont les pays étrangers en
afrique est haute et en fait c'est
l'institut français qui est à
l'initiative de ce 1 et qui permet
discours des intellectuels des écrivains
des romanciers de chaque région du monde
de participer avec
des auteurs de la france hexagonale sur
des débats de la société des beaux bad
des débats du moment qui
ah bon c'est des questionnements que je
pose le grand public et les lecteurs en
fait on est dans la peau là pour dans le
prolongement de deux lectures ouvrage du
roman des décès en sciences humaines
sciences politiques
donc c'est une manière de poser un
regard finalement sur l'évolution du
monde finalement enfin l'évolution
intellectuelle où il sert exactement les
bagnoles 2 de faire revenir dans
l'actualité le livre le monde de
l'édition les intellectuels ou à
l'accueil toujours par à la guinée parce
que dans la nuit des idées les
intervenants dans le cadre de la
martinique pour la villa chanteclerc
seront à la fois des sociologues des
philosophes des économistes
aïe il ya un jeune homme on va y venir
on va y venir la déclinaison programme
ici mais le concept global et puis
l'intention l'objectif aussi vous avez
dit il ya une dimension internationale
évidemment très importante 1 cet échange
comme ça entre entre les entre les
continents et les diverses sociétés
parlons de cette 6e édition maintenant
un peu plus particulièrement avec un
parent qui est hartmut rosa
oui à l'eau de rose à celle des parents
qui en deux philosophes allemands
intellectuellement qui va intervenir à
paris mais je vois tu cher aussi la
présence aussi de second parent dont 1
philosophes africains qui en scène à new
york
un jazz avec qui on va sans doute faire
un travail latéral eux
sur en combat en comparaison du ne leur
concept nouveau qui sont en train de
lancer c'est à dire le le point de
départ et le départ hélas de plus en
plus cela une visibilité de philosophes
du bol ce qu'on appelle du monde
occidental c'est à dire du sud par
rapport à l'europe ses latéraux et que
développe diane danser ou dans ses
ouvrages et dansé conte à new york aux
états unis
alors c'est un peu un peu le but
de trouver un cheval de troie important
qui a qui appose qui a eu à nouveau rage
à succès dans bond de l'année ayant sous
la thématique et de la et de l'imposer
et le choix en france
d'intellectuellement donc bien
l'ouverture que veut l'institut français
avec la nuit des idées sur sur son
rayonnement international
voilà allez donc la martinique eux il
prendra part ce jeudi
alors évidemment on comprend bien que ça
va beaucoup se passer par des connexions
numérique tout ça ce seront mes mais il
y aura aussi du présentiel on va arriver
on va y venir mais encore un mot parce
que donc le thème cette année ses
proches un proche au pluriel
alors parlez nous un petit peu de ce
thème particulier pour cette sixième
édition et puis laquelle quel sens ça
prend ici dans sa déclinaison
martiniquaise quoi bon le le thème fait
un clin d'oeil
[Musique]
largement à la fois physique
et aussi métaphorique à la situation
sanitaire du moment kif qui font que la
à cause de la pandémie les voyages le
plus c'est faire les échanges des salons
du livre à l'international ne peuvent
plus avoir
donc c'est un clin d'oeil qui qui est à
la fois partie de la pandémie mais aussi
de d'un débat d'idées c'est à dire que
montrer que que que dans dans la caraïbe
ou ailleurs la les problématiques
peut-être différente bon on va revenir
soins sur enfin un pont tant historique
que déchocage et statuts et 6 mais ça a
été long dostie ça a été les états unis
donc voici là l'aspect métaphorique que
culturel et intellectuel
que va rapprocher le beau mais aussi
dans une lecture directe lé le côté
proche physique mais aussi proches dans
les idées alors il s'agit effectivement
de constater de faire l'état des lieux
actuel mais de se mettre en perspective
aussi parce que je vois bon j'ai vu dans
la présentation générale
justement la nuit des idées 2021 24
heures pour se sentir proche au pluriel
eh bien on nous dit que le thème a été
choisi pour permettre d'interroger la
transformation des rapports c'est ce que
vous disiez à l'espace aux mobilités
dans ce contexte mais aussi des
nouvelles solidarités que la crise des
modèles économiques et sociaux appelle à
construire ou encore la place du
numérique dans nos sociétés tiens
justement à propos numérique je disais
donc tout ça va se vivre quand même
cette année dans une contexte inédit et
donc 24 heures de nuit et d'idées sur
différents
sur différentes plateformes facebook
youtube et puis sûr on peut aller voir
aussi bien sur toute cette affaire sur
l'adresse internet www.la nuit des idées
point com comment dirais-je plus de 200
nuits sont attendus à l'international
dans le monde
ici ça va se passer donc à la villa sont
eux claire à à fort de france
dites nous comment donc ce sera à partir
de 18h que l'on comment ça va se passer
avant de parler du programme les
modalités pratiques et puis est ce que
c'est une affaire de grand public où
c'est finalement c'est réservé à un
cercle d'une élite intellectuelle et
voilà c'est triés sur le volet le
contraire du moment c'est un événement
dont l'accès est libre et gratuit ouvert
à tous la chance de on a eu et le choix
de la villa chanteclerc c'est qui
la participation physique est possible
c'est à dire l'auditeur qui nous
écoutent aujourd'hui et qu'un envie de
venir écouter les intervenants et il
peut largement le faire dans le respect
de la jambe ou qu'on a qu'on a décidé à
l'habitation trop clair donc ce qu'il
faut savoir aussi c'est qu'on a apporté
une amélioration c'est le premier essai
qu'on fait c'est que dans les colloques
internationaux
il arrive souvent que pour des colloques
multilingue
les gens ont des émetteurs écouteurs
donc on a fait le choix de
de donner à chaque
visiteurs ce soir là un émetteur
écouteurs qui lui permettra de sa place
qui sera éloigné bien sûr du podium dans
les terminaux de pouvoir écouter la
totalité des intervenants dans une
qualité d'écouté et surtout cela qui est
de déplacement parce qu'il faut
respecter les gestes barrières sans
qu'on soit la sortir de son de son
fauteuil
et hop voilà et comme on est dans le
monde littéraire on n'est pas dans un
concert de groupes de musique de musique
c'est pas 400 personnes qu'on aura mais
les la centaine de personnes qui
viendront en qui sera sans doute là la
jauge grand maxi 1 tour 9 points
largement participé aux débats et aux
écoutes des intervenants alors quelques
mois encore sur le thème de cette année
et puis on va dérouler pour conclure on
vous allez préciser le déroulement même
du programme est cité quelques
intervenants mes proches proches ou
plurielle en martinique en ce moment
c'est vrai vous l'avez dit bon avec tout
ce qui s'est passé l'an dernier les
statuts cette quête identitaire
finalement qui poursuit mais aussi des
moments où on est proche on peut faire
corps union par exemple face à la crise
sanitaire mais on voit aussi beaucoup de
de luttes intestines ici ou là soit dans
le domaine politique économique des
mêmes d'aidé comment dirais-je des des
clichés finalement de caste aussi qui
ressurgissent il ya des résurgences est
ce que tout ça tous ces thèmes
finalement d'actualité bon eh ben ils
seront là aussi quelques passes qui
seront posées oui tout à vous redire la
parole sera libre
là effectivement l'encourager sur des
sujets très sensibles et bien sûr la
parole est libre
le shaq intellectuelle qui interviendra
dans son sujet où sont gravés et le
maîtrisent à 100% donc dans la liste des
invités ont le premier qui passera à
quatre agents kouzola avec une notion de
la représentativité mais et économique
delà de la nouvelle génération c'est
comment il conçoit la réussite sociale
et la réussite et que économique
est ce que cette réussite sociale et
économique qui indique où tommy avec les
notions qu'avait développé ces airs qui
est celle du peuple noir de la négritude
et on a aussi un médecin qui atteindra
qui est un
directeur de l'hôpital et qui est un os
et esprit qui est très meda sur la
problématique de la dépendance
alimentaire will et oncle curieux
l'affairé nous revoilà et une
indépendance alimentaire oui mais dans
le respect d'une agriculture bio bio
voilà il interviendra il ya un système
de questions et de réponses et
d'échangés avec le public
voilà en fait c'est de l'actualité du
monde
kinki nous qui nous fait vivre qui qui
font partie de deux du de l'adn de votre
travail de journalistes qui font que
vous apporter l'information aux gens les
gens réagissent et voilà nous
il digère l'information la la
transmettre à d'autres cela le débat ça
robert autour de ça très bien
on va citer une dernière intervention
qui vous disiez qui collent vraiment
justement à l'actualité y compris la de
ces derniers jours aux états unis par
exemple un communicant germinal pinalie
lui va intervenir sur ce questionnement
que restera-t-il désigné deux des idées
de bernie sanders donc candidat à
l'élection présidentielle de gauche
inquiets un socialiste américain et
c'est dans le gouvernement joe biden
kamala harris que restera-t-il de ses
idées de berne wilders ses devoirs de la
gauche aux états unis parce qu'elle
existe
et quand même elle est présente avec
quand ils rentrent s à new york et blaze
autres donc montré que si levante à sien
est haute et si important pour joe biden
c'est que la jeunesse de gauche de
californie et hop sont allés voter
dernières précisions pratiques
jean-benoît desnel pour conclure comment
faut-il faire donc pour participer enfin
pour s'inscrire et donc pouvoir
participer
écoutez ce qui sera dit et il n'y a pas
d'inscription la première on vieillit
voilà c'est la voix dans ce cas envie de
venir voilà ils sont investis s'épuisent
et que ça commence à 18h15 18h15 le
premier intervenant jean crusol sera là
pour ne pas perdre une miette de ce
qu'il a à dire c'est être présent
voilà dès le départ en gros de 18h à
20h30 21h voilà ce jeudi soir à la villa
sont claires à fort de france
entrée libre mais évidemment compte tenu
des conditions sanitaires avec jean les
gestes barrières seront respectés et il
ya une jauge de combien de personnes un
peu pas musarder merci bonne journée à
toutes et à tous à l'écouté de nos
programmes
[Musique]